we had honesty
be honest we had offensiveness
it was insulting it was offensive and we
wondered
is it okay it's okay it's okay
it shouldn't just be okay this is your
the bachelor greatest seasons ever
season one episode 10
big finale recap so grab your glasses
it's time for roses and rosie
hi everybody it's me lauren zema
oh it is so good to see everybody as we
start to talk about
the bad bachelor i speak the language of
love
yes this is juan pablo gallabies season
of the bachelor being recapped
in the bachelor greatest seasons ever
whatever you want to call it goat show
the greatest seasons ever and of course
we're gonna get
claire our bachelorette now a quick
update
i did tell everyone that my air
conditioning wasn't working
last week but as you can see i'm now
working
a long sleeve turtleneck what am i
thinking
well the truth is that some very kind
gentlemen came and checked everything
out and said ma'am
your air conditioning is working it's
just very hot
and the building you live in is poorly
made
great
so you know that was a lot to process
and on top of that i now have to process
the man dubbed the worst bachelor ever
so to comprehend it all i've poured
myself
a tequila
yes we're going oh hi
i have poured myself a tequila
yes to comprehend it all we have gone
to the next level we love our wine but
it's tequila time everybody
um and today i've got kind of just a
little rocks glass here and i have a
glacier ice cube
i love a glacier ice cube they're big
they're snazzy they're fabulous
wow let's get to it
oh i don't like recipes i don't measure
so
everything's always a surprise you know
it's like i'm really bad with directions
never
know where i'm going never know where
you might end up keeps it fun
so what happened that made juan pablo
season and his reputation go entirely
off the rails
so right off the bat don't drink every
time chris harrison says juan pablo was
the most hated bachelor
ever one of the most hated men in
america how did it all
rapidly go downhill from heartthrob to
heel in spectacular fashion
collision course to infamy yes
interestingly he was very beloved as he
was heading into being at the bachelor
he even said america wanted him to be
the bachelor
i am in this situation because america
wanted me to be the bachelor and by the
way i love the way he says
bachelor latino so i will give him that
i speak the language of love i see the
appeal
you know he was a single dad a former
professional athlete
good looking had the scruff and a sexy
accent
like i get it but juan pablo didn't
did he and we're gonna get to that okay
i'm beyond excited to meet him
and it can't come soon enough but of
course the reason this is the greatest
seasons ever finale is because it's
leading us into claire's season check
so right off the bat we're gonna get
claire
pregnant claire yes claire showed up
tonight one
and i only watched a little bit of this
season so i didn't remember this claire
showed up tonight one
um with a fake pregnant belly what do
you know about this let me see
this was like 2014. so this does give us
an
idea of how long claire has been waiting
to find the right guy
and start a family by the way touching
briefly on
claire's a poster her bachelorette
poster came out
and the line on it is it's about time
you know what i would have said worth
the wait because we've been waiting for
it claire
we've been waiting for your season
during the quarantine and you've been
waiting for love
and it's gonna be worth the wait i think
it's gonna be good
so what's great about this is it's a bit
of a clear ketchup if you didn't know
claire very well if you didn't watch her
on this season
or on paradise or on winter games
you know claire's kind of a nick vial
isn't she let's drink for every
franchise show claire's been on
if you didn't you can get to know her a
little bit here she's the youngest of
six women in her family and she did lose
her dad to cancer so she talks about the
importance of her dad my dad was
a wonderful man he even made a dvd
that she has never watched for her
future husband to watch one day before
he died i have not seen it
nobody's seen it but i'm saving it for
the right man to watch it
the question is is claire engaged right
now
has someone watched that dvd i want to
know i can't wait for the season
i can't wait i'm just gonna wait i just
wanna wanna watch it right now i just
wanna see it all happen i don't wanna
post it i want the actual episodes
wow um this is essentially a shot i
think
maybe two i don't know what's in here
kind of just tequila lime juice
and you know again reviewing juan pablo
season is about renewing our love for
claire
drink every time chris harrison says
we're gonna get to talk to claire on
this episode claire is here from
quarantine declare we'll share some top
secret details we'll hear the surprising
lessons she learned from being with him
and later our next bachelorette claire
joins us and fills us in
and what did claire have to do with it
so i'm just gonna say
a bunch of stuff happened and now we're
at the fantasy suites
drink for everything i fast forwarded
should you choose to forego your
individual rooms please use this key
to stay as a couple in the fantasy suite
now in the fantasy suites we do of
course have
more than claire we have some other
great ladies andy dorfman's here
everybody
yes andy dorfman is here and there is a
lot to
unpack here because andy goes into the
fantasy suites with juan pablo
yes andy dorfman has checked in and
she's got a big old suitcase
to unpack
talking about emotional baggage like the
unpacking of trauma
so andy comes out of the fantasy suites
with juan pablo
i could not wait to get out she should
be flying high
fantasy suite turned into a nightmare
she should be soaring
whole night was just a disaster but
instead
she's enraged
yes i was extremely upset i felt like
and i still feel like
juan pablo doesn't take this seriously
don't drink every time andy dorff have
been said
she knows it's over i know it's not
gonna work it's not even that i'm
i'm unsure like i know that i wouldn't
end up marrying him and i know that he's
not the one
so what happened here of course the
fantasy suites are the only part of the
show
not on camera actually some stuff is
also not on camera and a pretty critical
moment this season also happened and not
on camera we're gonna get to that when
it comes to claire so you know don't go
anywhere
and andy says that in this off-camera
time you know she thought juan pablo
would really want
to get to know her not once did he
really ask anything about me
about oh no no he did not
instead he talked about himself
all he wanted to do was kind of say it's
okay and give me a kiss
yes she says that juan pablo didn't ask
her anything about herself during the
fantasy suites
now she also says that ultimately she
feels like he doesn't really know her at
all
so crazy to think how little he actually
knows about me at this point
so i will say this that's a big red flag
it's not like he got dropped in the
fantasy suites if he doesn't really know
her at this point that means he also
wasn't asking her questions about
herself
during all the time they spend together
someone will say andy
should have dumped him sooner and i'm
not blaming her i'm not saying she's at
fault here i'm just saying let's all
learn from this situation you know
if somebody's not asking you questions
about you
on date one bye
any relationship needs to be a two-way
street who likes a one-way nobody
they're annoying they make you go in
circles you know what i'm saying
obey the rules of traffic all right and
also use your turn signals i've talked
about that before i don't like when
people don't do it
communicate but we love andy she's a
strong intelligent woman and she is
going to confront
the bachelor i have to
do what's in my heart and do what i
think is right and be true to myself
which means
telling juan pablo that i'm leaving and
we're really seeing what andy was
talking about aren't we
i mean she's talking and he's staring at
her
but he's not seeing her i came here
because i wanted to find love
he's hearing but he's not listening
despite all the great feelings and the
great adventures it
it wasn't going to work he's verbally
affirming
but he's not really saying anything it's
okay and he's certainly not making sense
no no no
okay as andy's explaining what went
wrong he says things like
all of us have thoughts going through
our minds i had a lot of thoughts
running through my mind and
all of us have friends what she tells
him she realized she doesn't love him
and he says
that's perfect i realized that i
wasn't in love with you who's within
that i'm like is it
and andy's starting to get annoyed and i
don't blame her because he's not making
sense
he's not acknowledging her feelings and
he does
say he respects her i respect you 100
but did he act like it i'm not sure it's
okay
i will say this for juan pablo the words
he
was saying were not wrong he said he
understood her and that he respected her
i just don't know if he really did what
do you think let me know in the comments
below
at the end of the day i think the reason
andy really is so upset is because
she feels like juan pablo and doesn't
know her i just never honestly feel like
you
were trying to get to know me and she
tests him don't drink for everything he
didn't know
any idea like what religion i practice
what my political views are what my hang
on what my you know
views on social issues things that
matter do you have any idea
how i want to raise my kids do you have
any idea about any of that
i have no idea about any of that and
then he tests her back
and she aces it what's my religion
catholic
things are escalating so don't drink
every time they say honest
i'm being honest i'm being honest i'm
being honest okay do i appreciate
honesty absolutely
it's offensive to you that i'm honest
and i say you
andy really gets riled up when she tells
juan pablo well you didn't ask me
anything about myself and he says
it's fine i've never been with someone
who's asked me so little about myself
it's fine it's not fine it's not
and that's when we get into it's okay
but if you don't feel it andy it's okay
yes juan pablo loves to say
it's okay it's okay it's okay it's okay
it's okay
forget it did i say you took it okay
juan pablo argued he was just being
honest though so what do you think was
he being honest
or offensive and was it okay forget it
did i say it's okay but of course andy
would go on to become the bachelorette
so she's okay
but now we're gonna get to our girl who
does hair yes everybody now we are
getting into
claire crawley and juan pablo galavis's
relationship on the bachelor so claire
was in the final
two and juan pablo didn't come through
no no no this relationship crashed and
burned like this straight tequila does
going down the throat
a little lime in there tart start
that'll wake you right up from this
quarantine dream
so we're on to claire but we're still
talking about honesty
since the day he blindfolded me in the
car juan pablo has told me to trust him
and then juan pablo says something
really
offensive it was insulting
it was offensive thematic it's a
thematic season
but it didn't happen on camera in one of
the most iconic moments in
bachelor franchise history juan pablo
and claire were in a helicopter
where there were no cameras no audio
nobody there with us so claire is upset
and she just has to explain that juan
pablo
said something inappropriate juan pablo
leaned over
and whispered something to me what i
thought was gonna be
sweet kind loving words was
not what came out of his mouth
apparently he said he doesn't really
know her but he does like
hooking up with her that he really
doesn't know me
and some sexual thing i don't even want
to repeat
yeah also i'm gonna guess that he didn't
say
hooking up with her you know what i mean
he self-admitted that he had kind of a
language barrier
english is my second language didn't
always know american phrases
if we're being honest my guess would be
that he probably phrased it in a more
blunt and and probably vulgar way
what do you think let me know in the
comments below so just like andy had to
do this is confront juan pablo
round a two he comes over to see claire
and he says well can i have a little
basito can i have this
is that okay i'm like i don't know
can you how about me though come on in
come on in i don't know i don't speak
spanish can you what does that mean
i had to look it up and it means a
little kiss and the answer is no you
cannot
no you cannot
but even though she denies the pacito
claire does
talk to juan pablo don't you know and
they kind of work things out
he explains to her that it was a bit of
a communication issue
you got me wrong and it's not that i
don't know you at all
and i don't know you enough he said you
don't know me enough that he didn't mean
he doesn't know her he just meant he
needs to know her better
in order to get engaged and he tells her
that she's
really special to him because i want you
to be here
so you're special to me no
no no
i could believe the don't know you like
meaning i need to get to know you better
communication issue oh god i got my own
hair on here
i might have gotten the ac fixed but i
haven't gotten a haircut okay
my hair gets everywhere it's a problem
but let's break down something here
because just like andy kind of missed
some red flags with juan pablo
i think claire missed one as well when
are we the most ourselves
when no one's watching if we're all
being honest
when do you do kind of the grossest
stuff you do
or the most embarrassing stuff you do
the things you don't want anyone else to
see when no one is watching
so when the cameras were down and juan
pablo had the chance to really be
himself
what he chose to tell claire was that he
liked
hooking up with her
that's a big indicator of who he is
claire what he said in that moment
he could have used that moment to say
hey
no one's watching us so i'm going to
tell you i want to pick you
but no no no he did not
not not so i wish he'd been dumped then
and there by our girl claire but things
didn't fare that way so
time for a proposalish
so claire is looking beautiful i am
loving that color on her
and she is going to juan pablo and she
tells him she's nervous
and he says of course it's okay
it's okay is it it's not
it's fine to be nervous i'm nervous too
yeah you know why would he tell her it's
okay
when he knows he's about to dump her and
he's doing the exact same thing he did
with andy
saying it's okay it's okay but not
listening
and not making sense i believed in you
he dumps claire and she says i thought
you were the man of my dreams and he
says
me too i've saved this moment for the
man in my dreams
and i thought that was you me too why
would he say that
if he's the one dumping her it just
doesn't make any sense you are not being
wronged here juan pablo gallaudez
and that's what makes me think that with
these women instead of listening
he is hearing he keeps waiting for her
to stop talking for you to sit there and
tell me
that you can see yourself in sacramento
that you can see yourself
we got together we have our babies
you know he keeps almost jumping in i
mean at one point he just makes a noise
and i thought i knew what kind of man
you are
um
okay don't drink every time he says
it's okay okay hey okay it doesn't
matter to me
i lost respect for you i would never
want
my children having a father like you
okay it is not
okay you are
dumping a woman who you had just talked
about having kids with it
is not okay
like maybe before with andy it was kind
of okay
if you don't think it's means it's okay
but now
it's really not okay
anyway you can see why juan pablo was
known as the most hated bachelor
i'm glad he didn't pick her but it's
proposal day
and we still have one woman left he's
gonna propose to nikki
right he's gonna redeem himself right
he's not no he's not uh and again he's
he's not making sense you know
at the point in time when you would
normally be professing your love to
someone
he starts saying things like it's been a
time it's been
a perfect time
and you have qualities you know the
qualities
and you want to be with a person because
you want to be with a person
what ultimately he tells nikki
he likes her a lot i like you a lot
a lot it's not okay
it was not okay he asks her if she will
accept his final rose
will you accept my final rose and she
does but
don't drink for this uncomfortable face
nikki makes as she decides
wish i could have given her a shot of
tequila this one's for you nikki
the problem with juan pablo is that he
never
redeemed himself i mean if we look at
some of the other disliked bachelors
jason mesnick made a mistake but wound
up with molly and they're happy
ari made a mistake but he's now with
lauren burnham and they're happy
juan pablo and nikki stayed together for
a little while um
at the after the final rose chris
harrison asked him
well are you now in love with nikki so
you love her
and not only was he not
but his response didn't make sense
so you love her i'm not gonna answer
that question to you
juan pablo said to chris harrison i'm
not gonna answer that
because you don't say that to people in
relationships
i'm not gonna answer that question to
you i don't i don't get it
this is real life you know and when when
you're with somebody you don't say you
love her or not
if you are there or not what
so they broke up and nikki is now
happily married i'm married
and more importantly claire is here
claire is here
oh god no no no
no no no
i gotta doctor this up just a snuggle
yes from quarantine on the set
of the bachelorette claire is joining
chris harrison a 4a
zoom uh he says that she was already
there of course he would have to go to
the set we're in quarantine because we
are about to start shooting your season
of the bachelorette
but claire was there claire is here
and what's interesting is that now that
we know that at one point
tasia becomes the bachelorette i am
hanging on
every word for clues
don't drink for everything that felt
kind of ominous and possibly indicative
of something happening even though these
two were talking before filming had
begun
chris harrison says if he does his job
correctly she'll find love
and hopefully about to meet the love of
her life if i do my job correctly
did he and i love hearing from claire uh
she says she's gone through a lot
and she loves herself and as somebody
who has
gone through a lot and learned to just
love herself and she could not be
more ready i could not be more ready for
this
claire is ready she says the most
important thing to her
is getting to know the person
real one-on-one connection and just
having the time to get to know each
other
so did she oh my god i'm exhausted
getting 10 000 steps doing this show i
mean chris says she'll probably
be engaged you're going to probably be
engaged is that wild to think
so is she let me give you a tour let me
give you a tour here oh and then we're
moving we're vlogging we are on a tour
claire is showing us where she is
staying for the show
she's showing us everything it's kind of
chaotic she's got her dogs
and she's got some crystals here are my
crystals
good energy and her bed this
is where the magic happens oh fantasy
sweets
and it's all happening and the episode
is over
and i'm so glad that we wrapped things
up with
claire because we are going to start
things again
for her season october 13th on abc the
new season of the bachelorette premieres
and of course we will be recapping and
reviewing it
for roses and rose remember it airs on
tuesdays this fall
because of the pandemic through off the
schedule they have to
not conflict with monday night football
sports
and the bachelorette is going to be on
tuesday so we will see you guys every
wednesday for roses and
rose covering the night before's episode
thank you guys so much for watching
roses and rose the bachelor greatest
seasons ever of all time
we love you so much and so much has
happened during quarantine
christine got pregnant she's having a
little baby girl maybe one day a future
bachelorette we don't know
and jc looking back at these seasons has
made me remember of course it's been you
and me
on this show from the beginning how
ready are you for the new season of the
bachelorette
cheers my friends
and cheers to all of you okay you guys
know we've been filming
at my apartment and so this is my
apartment and um
you know i've got i don't have crystals
but i have like this i got this at
marshall so this has great energy
and um thank you guys i am on cameo and
i am on twitter and i am on
tick tock and instagram and um i love
you so much thank you for watching okay
bye
you